let's start up a question right have you
heard of mine doll rhyme doll no no okay
so some people watching will have heard
of wind doll I'm going to talk about
what that is today
it's the album behind the advanced
encryption standard it's everywhere
absolutely everywhere so it's being used
to encrypt this video it's being used to
encrypt the connection from to the
server list which is producing the video
and so on it's being used if using
BitLocker to encrypt your hard disk and
so on and so forth the list goes on it's
being used everywhere why is this one
algorithm everywhere why are we not
using lots of different algorithms and
some are good and some are bad you know
you know we talk about algorithms from
time to time Dijkstra and stuff
Dijkstra's good at certain jobs and not
other jobs why is it that everyone's
using this one in me let's say 80s and
early 90s there was now women called DES
or the data encryption standard now this
was written by IBM and we can talk about
this in a different video but des had a
few problems the mote the biggest of
which was that it only had a 56 bit key
you know you might guess the key about
half way through research on average so
if you're doing it at random so that's
maybe 2 to the 55 operations now in the
80s that was probably quite difficult to
do but it became easier and actually des
got broken a few times by clusters of
computers and large dedicated circuits
and things like this so for a while what
happened was we used a process called
Triple DES right which is ways three
times but there's where instead of using
one 56 bit key you use three and you do
- three times right that's another thing
we can talk about another time but it's
three times slower - oh yeah it solved
the problem with the short key it didn't
solve the problem with the fact that
actually it's quite slow so what we
needed was you know the Internet was
coming on board that things are
happening encryption was getting more
and more important we need something
faster right so so in 1997 the National
Institute of Standards and technology's
in America put out a call and said we
want a new encryption standard so
instead of days for data encryption
standard we're going to go for the
advanced encryption standard I mean the
name says it all it's better it's going
to be better right now there were a few
that they wanted so support for a
different for a specific block lengths
of 128 bits different key sizes and
things but the main thing they said was
we want it to be as secure as Triple DES
but much much quicker and quicker Wan
not just your fast Pentium but also on
your smart card and on your mobile phone
and other mobile phones a particularly
big deal back then but you know and
you're not get 33 10 or whatever it was
you can imagine but this in the
cryptographic community went down quite
well they want to be they want to
produce core ciphers they want to test
out each other's ciphers and generate
new algorithms and so it was going to be
a competition and open competition des
was written by IBM and the we've helped
from the NSA should we say and was just
announced as a standard this was going
to be a different process we're gonna
have a proper competition anyone I mean
I was quite young at the time so not me
but anyone who wanted to could submit an
algorithm it would be sort of
scrutinized and if it was judged to be
the best among all the others then it
would be made into the Advanced
Encryption standard and it will become
you know Phipps accredited and it would
get a lot of use now at that time it
would get sort of local use in America
but as we've seen now you know worldwide
use the initial submission was closed in
May 1998 that was when the 15
submissions were sort of finalized and
then we had a valuation period where
cryptography small over the world could
try and attack these ciphers work out if
they had vulnerabilities how fast they
were and there were a number of
different criteria they were looking for
right because just not being able to
break the cipher it's actually not that
it's only one part of it right there's
lots of things so for example low memory
footprint efficient so not you know
using up too much electricity too many
CPU cycles fast obviously because that's
got to help the ability to deploy in
Hardware if the algorithm is totally
unusable when you try and make a
hardware dedicated chip to do it no one
can do that and that doesn't make any
sense so in March 1999 they had another
conference where they looked at what
they'd found out so far so they had
people talking about whether these
algorithms were secure and how fast they
were and people had tried implementing
them on hardware and reported how that
had gone five of them
issues were found with their security
such they were not secure enough so five
of them were discounted and then another
five were discounted because of you know
various other issues like they had the
same security as one of the others but
with slower right and things like this
and so in the end this got narrowed down
to five right so there was vine doll
serpent which was written in part by
Ross Anderson who's been on computer
file before Mars written by IBM rc6
written by the RSA organization who also
developed RSA encryption and two-fish
written by Bruce Schneier and others
Niels Ferguson and so on it came down
not just to which is more secure and so
it wasn't that we picked the most secure
one if there were lots of things too
perfect to be thought about so for
example wine Dahl performed very well on
lots of different devices so that was a
real positive serpent was probably the
most secure in a sort of a strict sense
of it it had the fewest attacks make any
progress on it at all and but it was
just a little bit slower than mine doll
for example and software so lots of
decisions in the end of vote was taken
and it was somewhere around 80 something
votes for Ryan doll and then 50 for
serpent ish and then some for the others
so Ryan Darwin Ryan doll was written by
two Belgian cartographers so yo and
Armen and Vincent Wyman they were
obviously in the cryptographic community
but you know we had big hitters like IBM
in in this competition so it was in some
sense a little bit of a coup but they've
they're they won but you know one of the
nice things about academia is that if
you perform good work people will notice
that work and hopefully you know it'll
it'll see some use right even if you're
just starting out or you're not as
established as some other researchers I
quite I quite like that the nice thing
about a AES is that it is an SP network
we already talked about SP networks in a
previous video and so in some sense IES
is actually quite similar now there are
some differences and we'll talk about
those in another video but in general
what we've got is we've got a series of
confusing substitutions that make our
life difficult of tracking back work
what we had before and some permutations
were moving bytes and bits around so
that it's difficult to keep track of
where the key was and where the where
the message was and you do this a few
times until the output bears no
resemblance to the input at all the way
they round our works is that
you can have different block sizes so it
can have 128-bit block sizes or 256 bit
block sizes for example the AES
specification only allows for 128-bit
blocks with 128 or 192 or 256 bit keys
right and that that's what everyone had
to adhere to
so in some sense AES is a subset of mine
Dahl but they're now interchangeable
right one is the other so when we talk
about AES we're talking about the
algorithm that was named rondell and
it's now become the advanced encryption
standard is that job done no I mean
we've chosen this surely you know
computers get faster there'll be a point
where maybe this is broken will they
have to be another advanced advanced
encryption standard
I mean maybe eventually the so there's a
few that's an interesting question
because so each of these algorithms had
what we would call a security margin
which was I guess how much better are we
gonna have to get it attacking these
things to break them and we're a long
way off as far as I can tell why there
are some obscure attacks on things like
related keys and where and but the
amount of I mean some of some of them
will require petabytes of data and of
encryptions and decryptions to even
slightly be brute force so none of these
are practical you know there's no issue
of breaking in anytime soon the brute
force a key on even 128 bit machine is
totally out of reach to to the hundred
and twenty eight operations is huge so
it would take some 100 trillion years
for the world's fastest supercomputer I
think I calculated as a while ago I
could be out of date now and you get
papers and other ciphers that come along
so for example there's another cipher
called ChaCha 20 which is arguably
slightly faster on very low cost devices
right so there are algorithms that
perhaps weren't in this competition that
could see some use but there's a good
reason to have standards they get
attacked the most to get tested the most
they get implemented the most so you you
soon realize what the problems are and
then you can rely on libraries like open
SSL that have a very very good
implementation for your needs
so in some sense something would have to
really go wrong for us to want to change
algorithm because of how established it
is and you know don't reinvent the wheel
if we're taking our 128-bit message and
we're just laying it out
in this order like this and then we're
going to start using doing our SP
networks yeah we're going to permute
we're going to substitute bytes and then
we're going to transform it into some
way where an attacker can't read what
the message used to be so there are a
few different